good luck out there champ you're gonna
need
[Music]
one reason storm and the next gens are
more efficient their ability to hold the
optimum racing line every single lap
when I'm afraid for the lucky sensation
storms in a class of his own and a big
reason for that training on the newest
cutting-edge simulators these machines
create a virtual racing experience so
real racers never even have to go
outside responsibility to hold that line
is like nothing we've ever seen four in
a row are you kidding me who percent
lower drag coefficient oh five percent
increase downforce
Akeno mashup 1.2 higher top speed you
are about to become the biggest brand in
racing movie deals in commercial product
endorsements - Chad you think you're
famous now will be rich beyond belief
mr. Stirling what is this about your
legacy every time you lose you damage
yourself
I'm sorry your racing days are coming to
an end
we can only hope that this race today
wasn't his last I decide when I'm done
how you feeling I can't go out on the
track and do the same old thing it won't
work it's futile there is this change
man you know what I do what I don't know
I got nothing I am so excited to train
you I like a challenge
ha ha I call you my senior project on
your nod got a sad the beach ate me
Jackson storm set a new record today
what he pulled off the fastest lap ever
recorded
how you feeling the latest record storm
inside you giving any doctor eats on a
queen this is my last chance Cruz last
if I lose I never get to do this again
don't fear failure be afraid of not
having the chance you have the chance
ace to watch you on TV flying through
the air you seemed so fearless
it was shining with that felt like
you'll never be as fast to store that
you can be smarter than him
the racing is the reward not to stop
standing
are 95%
way
[Music]
Oh